[Música]
hola bienvenidos aquí comienza una nueva
emisión de ellos hoy en france 24
kamala harris es la única senadora
afrodescendiente en el congreso de eeuu
y ahora también la primera mujer negra
que aspira a la vicepresidencia por un
gran partido y sólo la cuarta mujer en
la historia del país que llega a una
fórmula vicepresidencial la senadora
demócrata es la apuesta de joe biden
contra el presidente de donald trump
para las elecciones presidenciales del 3
de noviembre a la luz de su candidatura
y con una historia como fiscal y como
congresista ella misma reconoce que aún
falta mucho camino por recorrer para las
mujeres en la política
si llega a ser elegida el 3 de noviembre
junto a joe biden a harris será la
primera mujer la primera afroamericana y
la primera asiática estadounidense en
ocupar la vicepresidencia en la historia
de los eeuu aquí su perfil y los
detalles de su nominación
un reporte adaptado por luis mendez
zúrich
meses de especulación llegaron a su fin
el 11 de agosto joe biden aspirante a la
presidencia por el partido demócrata
anunció que sería kamala harris su
compañera de fórmula en la carrera hacia
la casa blanca tengo el honor de
anunciar que he elegido a kamala harris
una luchadora intrépida y de las mejores
servidoras públicas del país como mi
compañera de fórmula
por esa misma red social harris
respondió al anuncio en sus palabras
expresó sentirse honrada por el
compromiso y resaltó que hará todo lo
posible por convertir a bailén en
comandante en jefe
de esta manera harry se convierte en la
primera mujer afroamericana en ser
nominada para tal cargo por uno de los
dos principales partidos políticos en
eeuu
adicionalmente es la cuarta mujer en la
historia en ser parte de una dupla
presidencial ex fiscal general del
estado de california
harris se ha dado a conocer por un
estilo agresivo al interrogar en el
senado tuvo alguna comunicación con
funcionarios rusos por algún motivo
durante la campaña que no haya sido
revelada públicamente a este comité
puedes comer
harris de 55 años presume de una
historia relativamente centrista en
temas como la atención médica
a su experiencia en el área de la
justicia había permitido desarrollar una
habilidad para la conexión personal la
gran mayoría de nosotros tenemos mucho
más en común de lo que nos separa y
tenemos que aferrarnos a ese
conocimiento aunque tengamos defectos
aunque seamos imperfectos vale la pena
luchar por este país harry se había
postulado para liderar su propia campaña
hacia la presidencia donde su principal
rival había sido el propio biden a quien
terminó expresando su apoyo tras
retirarse de la contienda para bailén
quien cumplirá 78 años en noviembre la
elección de una compañera de fórmula
tiene un significado especial ya que por
su avanzada edad es probable que sólo
cumpla con un mandato dejando a harris
como posible candidata para el año 2024
para el análisis invitamos a aeb y carga
y leia es politóloga y profesora en
ciencia política en la universidad de
california state university ayby gracias
por estar con nosotros
buenos días cómo se encuentran gracias
por tenerme usted es estadounidense de
ascendencia guatemalteca desde su
historia de inmigrante qué opinión le
merecen las críticas que se han dado en
las últimas semanas a kamala harris por
ser hija de una mujer india esto por
parte de donald trump
sí creo que una fortuna es un negativo
un afortunado por la razón de que estos
fueron los mismos a los mismos las
mismas críticas que él levantó contra el
presidente barack obama
no estamos sorprendidos de que de que ha
levantado estas críticas pero es sin
afortunado porque hay mucho mucho
americano mucho estadounidense de raíces
inmigrantes que constitucionalmente
tienen él tiene la credencial para poder
correr para una de estas posiciones
electorales mire y la esperanza de
kamala harris como vicepresidente
incluso podríamos decir que sobrepasa
fronteras sería un paso importante hacia
la igualdad de género y un ejemplo que
necesitamos en el mundo usted qué opina
si de seguro afortunadamente los eeuu ha
estado un poco con respecto a
poder elegir a una presidenta o
vicepresidenta con que siendo mujer así
que si gana bytes y gana a joe biden
kamala harris en noviembre sería un
símbolo y de progreso no sólo a través
de género pero también a través de
más que nada por ser es también siendo
una persona bis racial
y también la hija de inmigrantes así que
sería una símbolo extremamente grande
recordemos además que hillary clinton se
refirió en los últimos días también a
esta nominación de kamala harris
diciendo que espera que a partir de su
posición junto a joe biden pues la
política estadounidense sea menos
sexista y estos son las palabras de una
de las mujeres más fuertes en política
en eeuu
si afortunadamente la campaña de geolit
contiene el 2016 y también en el 2008
ella sufrió muchos ataques sexistas y
muchos ataques que normalmente un
candidato que es hombre no tiene que no
tiene que lidiar a la política americana
quiso creer por mucho tiempo de que
habían progresado y que habían por y que
se habían movido de la posición de que
una mujer no podía hacer a la presidenta
pero en afortunadamente en el 2016 nos
dimos cuenta de que existe más sexismo
en la política americana de lo que
originalmente habíamos pensado y que
habíamos encontrado científicamente en
estudios politólogos buyvip joe biden
entrevistó a unas diez mujeres en la
búsqueda de una fórmula vicepresidencial
hace unos minutos usted nos explicaba
algunas de las características que hacen
de kamala harris un personaje ejemplar e
importante como fórmula vicepresidencial
pero porque fue superior el perfil de
harris web por ejemplo frente a otras
candidatas una de ellas incluso era
latina
claro pues más que nada creo que no
puedo no estuve
en las conversaciones con respecto a
cómo y qué hacer y qué iba a hacer ayer
es la mejor candidata pero por verla y
estudiar su carrera se puede ver de qué
que la señora pérez o la senadora xerez
perdón es más que capaz es súper
aguda es astuta y tiene la experiencia
electoral y la experiencia profesional
para académica para poder ser la
vicepresidenta en enero y si y si es
también un afortunado a ser la
presidenta y ella tiene las
características necesarias para poder
tratar de unificar el partido demócrata
para ella sirve como símbolo no sólo del
partido demócrata pero sino de joe biden
de que están interesados no sólo en
agarrar a los votos normales sino que
también asegurar de que la comunidad
afroamericana quien es una base
importantísima para el partido demócrata
se ha reflejado en la administración si
es que llegan a ganar así que la
senadora general es ésta es más que
capaz
y merece tener a la nominación en la
manera que la recibió se ha probado como
una persona que puede tomar la posición
en cualquier en cualquier momento bueno
quiero hablar precisamente de la
comunidad afrodescendiente en eeuu
estamos en el contexto de blacklight
smarter de la brutalidad policial y
entonces kamala harris se presenta como
un personaje que puede ser un estandarte
de la lucha por los derechos de la
comunidad afrodescendiente sin embargo
en su pasado como fiscal fue criticada
por no buscar investigaciones en casos
de asesinatos de ciudadanos
afroamericanos entonces puede ser esto
un arma de doble filo para ella
claro que sí puede ser una arma de doble
filo y hasta cierto punto creo que en
parte por eso ella no pudo recaudar
mucho más apoyo en la comunidad
afroamericana cuando ella corrió para la
presidencia am hace unos meses así que
la campaña se va a tener que la campaña
de padre níger se van a tener que
prepararse para poder contestar las
preguntas sobre esta controversia y no
más porque la señora la senadora general
es más que capaz no quiere decir que
tampoco no se le puede criticar su
récord como como fiscal y como también
como procurador o procuradora general
del estado de california
de seguro ellos se van a tener que
preparar para poder dar una buena
respuesta y una respuesta genuina con
respecto a por qué ella no nos siguió
esos casos y como piensan cambiar eso si
es de que ganan porque ella va a tener
me imagino que una parte
y ella va a jugar una parte importante
sí desde que ellos ganan en
ayudar a resolver los problemas que
estamos viendo raciales en este país ya
nos estamos acercando al cierre pero hay
otro tema que llama mucho la atención y
es que en camel harris es una mujer
joven frente a su fórmula presidencial
joe biden que es un hombre ya de
avanzada edad y que posiblemente no
podría asumir un segundo mandato como
podrían aspirar normalmente los
demócratas entonces diríamos que esta es
una posibilidad de catapultar a kamel a
jarvis para que en un futuro no muy
lejano
ella misma pueda aspirar a la boleta
presidencial
yo creo que sí yo creo que como le dije
como dije anteriormente a la senadora
ángeles es más que capaz ella puede
asumir la vicepresidencia y si es
necesario también la presidencia
sería no estaría sorprendida si el
vicepresidente biden está pensando nomás
en un término aunque normalmente ningún
ningún candidato a la presidencia piensa
eso normalmente a ese es conocido de que
quieren los dos términos pero en un caso
de que él no pueda o ya no quiera asumir
a la presidencia en el 2024
la senadora xerez quedaría en una
posición muy oportuna para que ella
corriera y ascender ascendiera a la
presidencia y terminar un segundo
término hasta cierto punto
el vicepresidente paren ahí y de ella
pues muchísimas gracias a eb y por la
información que nos da y por el análisis
que hace del perfil de kamala harris que
también ha sido mencionado muchas veces
o citada como la obama femenina algo que
ella ha negado y dice que ella misma
quiere tener su propio legado vamos a
estar pues atentos nos quedan menos de
tres meses para las elecciones en eeuu y
aquí está france24 para hacer el
seguimiento a ibi que tenga un feliz día
gracias igualmente ha sido un placer y a
ustedes los invitamos a continuar con
toda nuestra programación en france24 y
como es costumbre nos vemos próximamente
en ellas hoy
[Música]